[Music]
my name is Jim McLaughlin I'm a national
chess master I've been playing chess for
50 years
tonight we're continuing our sessions on
chess tactics all these examples are
taken from the book the game of chess by
signor tarish published in the United
States in 1935 tonight's topic is
destruction of a guard so we previously
covered pinning and double attacks and
unguarded pieces okay our first example
white to play and win now remember it's
destruction of a guard so we see that
the White Queen is attacking the black
Queen the black Queen is protected by
the king the White Queen is also
attacking the black bishop but that
black Bishop is protected by both king
and queen so it's likely not the bishop
that's the target of the combination who
would like to propose a solution just go
ahead and speak up I have a hard time
seeing you rook to h8 yes the bishops
pinned it draws the King away from the
Queen allowing Queen takes Queen so this
is a simple example but it gives the
basic idea all the examples tonight
we'll be taking away the guard of some
important piece this example you can
build on what we did last example it's
pretty straightforward who sees the
winning move for white
right it gets right back into the
variation we just looked at so the
bishop takes the pawn the queen takes
and then again the work draws the King
away this is another fairly simple
example the thing to look for in this
case black wins how can black destroy
one piece that's guarding another who
would like to propose the solution do
you see it no okay let's say analyze it
just a little bit both the rooks the
black works that one is attacking the
bishop one is attacking the knight now
the bishops protected by a pawn the
pawns not being attacked so you can't
draw the protection away from the bishop
that leaves the knight
what's protecting the knight the bishop
can black destroy the bishop and that's
the answer so the answer is rook takes
III pawn takes and then the Knights
unprotected rook takes Knight and you
win two pieces for a rook and you're
you're left with a winning game I think
yeah you're what you're left with a
winning game but anyway it's not so much
to win the game as the to get the point
of destroying the guard which is the
bishop at e3 oh this is real simple well
it's a it's got a little twist at the
end but you can see in analyzing the
position that the White Queen is
unprotected that's always a danger you
will also notice that the black queen is
on the line with the White Queen but
there's a wreck in the way
so this is pretty straightforward who
would like to propose the solution here
Jason yep where rook d1 Queen takes rook
yeah you're right rook to g3 check White
has to protect the Queen now what's the
move similar to our first example you
need to draw the White King away from
the Queen again
so what move will do that
if the answer is rook to g1 check the
King takes through cleaving the Queen
unprotected just kind of like our first
two examples okay
both sides have three pawns both sides
have a rook and two pieces okay let's
look at what's attacking what the Black
Knight is obviously attacking the b2
pawn and the a3 pawn behind the black
knight the rook is attacking once the
knight moves would be attacking the
knight at c3 now we remember we want to
either destroy the guard itself or make
it move somewhere else now in this case
the pawn at b2 is trying to protect two
different squares a3 and C 3 that is
overworking that that little pawn and
that leads us to the correct move for
black who sees the winning move for
black Julian right night-night a3 and
plan takes Knight and then the knight is
free so we drew the protecting pawn from
B 2 to a 3 allowing rook takes Knight
and obviously even here the ape three
pawns in trouble and black has two pawns
on the Queen side versus one so it
should should be an easy win for black
all right
I don't remember the solution but it
looks like black has the winning chances
the black has a rook for a bishop
and he has his rook and queen are in a
strong attacking position though White's
King stuck in the corner so I think it's
pretty simple similar to what we already
saw in the first two examples so who
would care to propose the solution here
do you see it black to move in win
what's the strongest black Queen move
can the black Queen attack the King and
what square would that be so the Queen
can't the black Queen can check the King
on e5 so that's the move Queen to e5
check the King can't retreat so the
Queen has to interpose yourself right
now we have the old thing of the drawing
the King away from the Queen so the
winning move is now rook to h1 check he
has to try King to g2 but it doesn't do
any good because we have work to g1
check King takes Queen takes Queen check
White has six pawns black has four White
has a queen on d4 notice that it's on
the same line as the White King but we
can't play Bishop to c5 pinning the
Queen because the knight on a four guard
c5 now the white rook is on f3 notice
that the the whites first rank is
unprotected by a rook Queen or any piece
so that II 1 square is open
further notice that the black bishop not
only has the potential Bishop to c5 if
the knight wasn't there but the bishop
can attack on the kingside to the h2
pawn it's attacking the h2 pot we the
the black rook is not helping black in
this case because it's hiding behind its
Queen rook pawn so the black rook is out
of it
that pretty much means whatever we're
going to do has to be done with the
Queen and Bishop any would anyone care
to propose the winning move for black
okay well I will Queen to e1 check
forces the the work to retreat and
Bishop takes pawn check drawing the King
in this case away from the rook King
takes Queen takes for quitting the upon
and in exchange let's analyze this
position a little bit White has a queen
on d4 attacking the Black Knight and
defending the pawn the Queen it again is
on the same line with the black King
once again there's what Knight a white
knight on Queen rook 4 though preventing
the move Bishop to c5 pinning the Queen
to the king both rooks look like they're
developed in a similar fashion the white
rook is on e 1 and F 1 and black is on e
8 + f8 difference being that the white
work on f1 is attacking the pawn on f5
which is only defended by the rook so if
it was White's move he could win upon
where it takes pawn or Bishop takes pawn
of course we want more than that
I have a sneaking suspicion black wins
the example starts out with white making
a blunder so we have to make the blunder
first Bishop takes F five question mark
that makes things much easier for us now
let's look at it a little bit more
number one the rook on e one looks like
it's pinning our Knights it's only
protected by the white rook on f1 and
notice of course you notice that the
knight can jump to f3 with check
breaking the pin and attacking the white
queen so since our topic is distracting
or destroying the guard in this case the
guard is the work on f1 so how can we
move the guard from f1 somewhere else in
the answer is pretty obvious at this
point rook takes f5 winning a piece if
rook takes rook then we have the art we
do our knight check rook takes Knight
Queen takes and lo and behold we can get
the same position that we just looked at
it a minute ago and draw the King away
but this is better position remember
when we look at this position earlier
the black rook was on
Queen rook eight or eight now that's on
e85 is okay let's see what we have here
blacks Queen and rook are look like they
are deep in the whites territory one the
black queen is on c2 the rook
East seven they're attacking the night
and the queen is attacking the bishop
isn't it so we're attacking two pieces
unfortunately for white one piece is
defending both the knight and the bishop
again this is not just destroying the
are just distracting the guard but it's
also an example of an overworked
defensive piece the white rook on f1 is
overlooked overworked in that it's
trying to defend both the knight and
bishops so I think that makes the answer
pretty clear it must be your takes
Knight rook takes rook Queen takes
bishop check and it is now notice that
if the rutger treats an attack the Queen
that won't cut it because we have Bishop
to d4 check forcing the King away and
then we have Queen takes rook so the
only move is Queen to h7 but the
analysis stops so that was our example
for distracting and the garden we won we
have two pieces for a Rick and with the
clearly probably well I'd like to say
it's clearly winning it probably is the
two bishops so I think black prey wins
that pretty easy okay this one is really
simple the white queen is attacking the
black queen on d5 the black queen is
defended by the rook conveniently for
white the black King is in the corner on
h8 and also conveniently for a white
white has rook on f1
okay so this is pretty straightforward
who would like to propose the solution
to this problem well I'll go ahead and
propose it I know you some of you see it
the winning move is rook to f8 check if
FERC takes rook obviously Queen takes
Queen so the only move is the King to
move up now we get the our work on f8 is
attacking both routes notice that all we
have to do is draw the work on d8 away
from protecting the work on 8 and we win
a rook so Queen takes Queen rook takes
rook rook takes rook
let's analyze this position a little bit
the most obvious defect in blacks
position he has doubled pawns he is the
pawn on c6 double pawns are weak in this
case it is protected by the Queen
another defect in blacks position is his
black scoid Bishop has no squares to
move outward he can only retreat to f8
and if he retreated to f8 notice he
would leave his Knights under protected
and we could do bit white could do
Bishop takes Knight pawn takes Bishop
and those double pawns are even worse
than the ones on the Queen side the pawn
on f6 and f7 Plus with the White Knight
hovering about f5 or h5 White would have
a winning advantage after Bishop to F a
Bishop takes Knight so that strikes us
blacks enter pawns aren't all that bad
the three little pawns on the Queen side
c c7 c6 and d6 as long as they're
together like that they cover lots of
center squares the pawn on c7 protects
the d6 pawn
so black's pawn position per se in the
center isn't that bad whites better of
course cuz white doesn't have a double
pawn he's got a pawn on d3 protecting
his e4 pawn Knight on g3 protects c4
pawn the Burke protects the pawn and
whites Bishop is obviously superior to
blacks whites Bishop has is on the long
diagonal hitting the knight on f6 and
the pawn behind it so white has a clear
advantage I remember this one so I can
tell you for a fact that the author is
up to his old trick he makes a blunder
for black then our winning move will
become much clearer so black plays the
very bad d5 question mark that get
allows us if we want to we can advance
our pawn and drive the night away from
its protect protective square so let's
say we do that where can the knight go
to he can't go to h5 that's covered by
our queen and Knight and he can't go to
a four that's covered by our d3 pawn he
can't retreat cuz all the white squares
are covered by his pieces and pawns
Queen on d7 rekha-ii e8 pawn on h7 looks
to me like the only square he can move
to his Knight to g4 of course our Queen
hits the g4 square but it is protected
by his queen we could hit the knight
with the H pawn and drive it back if you
go back to Knight h6 it might be not a
good square for it but it wouldn't be
lost anyway but let's rewind it
we do pawn up Knight to g4 remember we
want to break the guard the guard is the
queen what's the winning move to break
the connection between the black queen
and the black knight on g4 Kirlian ecigs
the pawn threatens the queen and is
protected by the rook so the Queen can't
take it the pawn on f7 takes it that
breaks the connection to the queen and
night and then Queen takes Knight wins
the piece so that worked rather well
nice win for whites okay our last
example for destruction of a guard let's
see what we have here it's kind of a
messy position to me let's start with
white White's Queen and Bishop are
attacking the pawn on h6 but they're
defended adequately by the Queen on f8
the bishop on g7 it could be I don't
remember it may come to me but what
let's run through white and then we'll
run through black now the white knight
doesn't appear to be attacking anything
it's way back on e 2 so it's not doing
anything it's not even defending any
good squares I except for d4 the white
rooks well they work on D ones not bad
with the Queen they threaten Queen takes
pawn on d6 I guess you'd have to say
that's whites only threat the White King
work is inactive and obviously the White
King is exposed on c2 not to mention the
fact his paw
on b3 is attacked by the black pawn on
c4 so Weis in trouble so I'm gonna have
to go with Julian black must win this
now blacks most obvious move your eyes I
don't know I always tend to look at
checks first so pawn takes pawn check
looks like we would have to do work pawn
takes then what Oh c4 very good c4
attacking the pawn on b3 and if the pawn
on b3 takes c4 it opens the line for the
black work on b8 to take the pawn on b2
I think you just solved it let's see oh
it was White's move that makes a
difference
go he takes pawn I still go with your
line though nope
oh look now the Queen and rook the rook
protects the oh and that's the check
isn't it okay so the author had white
make a blunder again that let's say at
least a question mark if that's probably
a double question mark move because
Knight up check breaks the rook
protecting the Queen yes the new work
takes then pawn takes and the Queen is
still okay well anyway that's the end of
the example so I had a sneaking
suspicion that we might run out of
examples on this topic so I prepared
another topic the next topic in the book
and we'll jump right into it is called
Ellis sorry protection and quite simply
that just means it looks like a pieces
protected
by say a pawn but it's not an effective
protection maybe the pawn is pinned
against a king or a queen or a rook so
you take the piece anyway and the Queen
takes back and then well if it's a kink
the pawn can't move so it's no
protection at all if it's a queen of
rook the pawn takes and you win the the
piece behind the pawn so that's the
basic idea let's run through a couple
examples it's black smooth now White's
King is stuck in the center you see he
moved his King to d1 at some point and
he can't castle that's very bad the
Black Knight isn't a nice attacking
position on d5 protected by the bishop
and the pawn white does have his Bishop
and Knight developed and if he could
make a few moves he might get his Knight
to c4 or efore and actually do something
but he has a longer term problem and how
does he get his Queen work into play
he's got to move his king somewhere and
then move the rook in to play maybe he
should move his king over to e one and
try to get his rook to d1 maybe that
would be reasonable but it's blacks move
let's look it's blacks attacking moves
the Black Knight has an attacking move i
I wouldn't play it yet though because
the knight is well posted right on d5
but maybe it'll come in the future
he can play Knight to f4 attacking the
Queen and the G to pawn and it also
opens up the line for the black white
squared Bishop to get come down into a
White's position I don't see any attack
Wow I don't see any good attack emus for
the black bishop on e6 if he moves that
bishop white could trade Queens I'm sure
white would love to trade Queens and at
least get to an ending obviously black
spawns that are not in contact with
White's pawns or pieces so they have
nothing to do with it
that leaves the black rook its inactive
behind the a pawn so the most obvious
piece to move to the attack is to the
work where we should in black movies
wreck Julian right now he attacks the
pawn on b2 we're getting we don't have
the we're getting to where we're going
to have a guard that can be distracted
well one other thing that I forgot to
point out notice that the knight on d5
can hit c3 with check and the king and
queen are very conveniently lined up for
a knight fork so a blunder for a white
which is in the author's example he has
a couple blenders rook to b8 b1 that
doesn't cut it does it because now we
destroy the guard of C 3 which is the
pawn on B to protect preventing the
knight check with rook takes pawn
temporary work sacrifice rook takes rook
Knight to c3 check wins similarly
another way to protect the b2 pawn would
be let let me call my notation here the
other possible bad defense is Knight to
c4
and again work takes pawn does the same
thing
the difference being the knight moves
better than the Rick move because when
the Rick move Rick takes bond threatened
Rick takes your check and the knight
Fork now we just threaten the knight
fork and so he can move his king and at
least avoid losing the Queen but he lost
the key pawn now another way there was a
better way to defend the pawn there's
two other ways to defend the pawn on b2
upon on b2 is a black square White has a
black squared bishop so it could move to
d4 and protect the pawn similarly the
King is one Square way and it could move
to c1 and protect the pot so Bishop to
d4 that the author points out that you
don't only have to look at protecting
the pawn you have to think about
protecting the function upon add the
pawns funky function was to defend the
c3 square that's why the rook and Knight
don't work because they don't operate on
a diagonal like the pawn but the bishop
works because the bishop works on the
diagonal and obviously rook takes pawn
bishop takes guards to c3 square black
still has a big advantage positionally
but that's not the point of this
exercise and finally black could try
keek to c1 and no of course the King can
move on a diagonal so if rook takes King
takes the king guard c3 so the King
would replace the function of the b2 pot
but the computer really hates King to
see one it says black is winning the
game whereas with the bishop move or the
knight move black merely has the much
better game so this is a little bit of a
sideline who could say why King to c1 is
a losing position for white there's no
immediate combinations it's a positional
sort of thing
Julian yeah that's a good ideas remember
I said White's biggest problem is
getting his Queen rook into play on a1
King to see one actually makes it harder
because now the white work it only can
to go to b1 or back to a 1 and the other
thing we're at the note is that to the
right of the King all those back row
squares are open and it's possible that
black could come up like Julian said
Queen f8 to be for that and a 4 that
looks very strong black could also play
with moving Queen to h5 and dropping it
down to h1 check but it looks like white
has a defense to that by dropping its
Queen back so I think I'll go with
Julian's attacking idea has the best
idea okay again that this topic is Ellis
or protection I'm gonna have to say I
believe black is the attacker here
notice that blacks Bishop on f6 comes
down to c3 and attacks the pawn on b2
and attacks the knight on c3 so the pawn
on b2 protects the night if we can get
rid of that pawn the Knights unprotected
I think just like the other example
black Moses worked to be eight attacking
the pawn and if work takes notice how
convenient this works that rook takes
pawn
Bishop takes and the bishop conveniently
attacks two rooks getting the exchange
back and having one upon so that's
pretty straightforward
well this is very simple notice that the
two white rooks are attacking the two
black knights the Black Knights are
defended by one pawn well remember we
talked about an overworked defensive
piece where that pawn is the perfect
example the best way to take for white
is rook takes c6 the computer says rook
takes c6 gives a big advantage but rook
takes c6 is winning out right when
teamed pawn takes rook takes now I think
the reason why taking on c6 is better
notice that that pawn on c6 is
completely undefended and if we did the
other the pawn would be on e6 and the
King could move up and the RIC could
move over and defend it black might put
up a little resistance but so Burke
takes c6 is the best approach in this
case we're attacking the knight
the night with a pawn but our pawn is
pinned so obviously we want to break the
pin with Queen to g3 and the author has
black take the worst move Knight to g4
this is so easy Queen takes Knight when
have peace upon spin Ellis re protection
it only looks like the pawns protecting
the night well it looks to me like
whites attacking you know the author so
well the White Queen is attacking align
the long diagonal if that Knight gets
out of the way the pawn on g7 is pinning
allowing Queen takes rook pawn check
waits turned white just takes the pawn
the knight was protecting the pawn but
obviously he can't do Knight takes trick
check me something somebody makes the
plunder here because the physicians
don't look that bad do they so let's go
right into it
Oh white makes the horrible move who
would care to solve the last problem for
tonight
go ahead Ben right the pawn doesn't
protect anything because it's pinned so
h3 is definitely the worst are one of
the worst moves on the board that covers
we got through two topics tonight that's
great thanks
[Music]